[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Klaus Kleber
guten Abend das ist eine seltsame Zeit
im Nachrichtengeschäft schon lang ein
Virus wirft einen so gewaltigen Schatten
auf die Landschaft das Vorgänge
unbeachtet bleiben die normalerweise
Sondersendungen provozieren würden denn
es geht um Krieg und Frieden Russland
genauer gesagt wladimir Putin hat sein
Militär Waffen Logistik und Soldaten
östlich der Ukraine derart konzentriert
und aufgestellt das Putin keine Worte
mehr braucht um seiner Forderung
maximalen Nachdruck zu geben der Westen
soll sich raushalten aus Moskaus
Einflusszone und westliche Spionage
Satelliten sollen ruhig selbst die
Aufnahmen machen die den Westen unter
Druck setzen unser Korrespondent Axel
Storm ist unterwegs an den Grenzen der
Ukraine zu Russland und Belarus und er
ist in der Hauptstadt Kiew ein Bericht
aus einem Land das allen Grund hat
nervös in das nächste Jahr zu gehen
Knoblauch Zwiebeln rote Beete natürlich
Dill klassischer wird es nicht
patriotischer auch nicht Svetlana und
Svetlana verpacken getrocknete Zutaten
für Borscht
wir machen ukrainischen Borsch für
unsere Soldaten an der Front ein Paket
ergibt 5 Liter Borscht das sind 10
Portionen die kräftige Suppe für die
Männer an den Waffen ist
spendenfinanziert die Regierung Tour zu
wenig für die Soldaten sagen die beiden
Svetlanas deshalb sind sie Teil der
sogenannten Köchinnen Hundertschaft
ich schaue mir die Dinge realistisch an
ich sehe dass unser Land geografisch
zwischen Russland und Europa liegt wir
müssen für unser Existenzrecht kämpfen
wir haben keine Wahl
Suppenlöffel und Küchenmesser als Waffe
das Mark amüsieren angesichts dieser
Bilder aber gibt es wenig Grund zu
spaßen Putin hat eine Drohkulisse
aufgebaut die die Welt in Atem hält wohl
100.000 russische Soldaten und schweres
Gerät an der Grenze zu Ukraine der Kreml
fordert vom Westen keine Osterweiterung
der NATO der Westen schwankt zwischen
Skepsis und Zurückhaltung sucht nach
Antworten wir fahren hin zur Grenze ins
Dreiländereck Belarus Russland Ukraine
verlassene Häuser viele alte Menschen in
einem kleinen Dorf lernen wir Natalia
kennen die Russen sind ihr zurzeit nicht
so wichtig wichtig sind ihr die Hühner
aber Angst vor dem Krieg hat sie schon
natürlich haben wir Angst mein Sohn hat
mal gefragt Mutter was machen wir wenn
es Krieg gibt ich habe gesagt ich weiß
auch nicht wohin wir dann gehen
grenzoffizier Alexei zeigt mir wie es
auf der anderen Seite aussieht wir
kraxeln den 15 Meter hohen Wachturm
hinauf und sehen
weniger von hier aus sind es weniger als
100 Meter bis nach Russland wir sehen
Sicherheitsinfrastruktur sie ist weiß
das kann man gut sehen
alle hier wissen nichts zu sehen heißt
nicht dass die Gefahr nicht da ist dabei
werden sie hier täglich erinnert an die
Traumata die der Nachbar selbst
ausgelöst zumindest aber unterstützt hat
ein Sohn der Stadt er starb im Kampf
gegen die Pro russischen Separatisten im
Osten und auch die Krim Annexion hat
niemand vergessen im Dorf treffen wir
auch Anatoli er ist sich sicher Krieg
wird es nicht geben
Moskau weiß doch dass viele Anwohner
hier russisch stämmig sind glauben Sie
wirklich sie sind so dumm ihre eigenen
Leute zu töten
was tun gegen die Moskauer drocolisse
mehr Sanktionen die Gaspipeline Nord
Stream 2 lahmlegen mehr Dialog in der
Ukraine bereitet man sich auf das
Schlimmste vor der Westen scheint
bislang noch keine gemeinsame Strategie
zu haben
eines hat Putin schon erreicht am 10
Januar kommen in Genf russen und
Amerikaner zusammen um über diese Sache
zu reden vielen in Europa gefällt das
nicht aber reden ist wenigstens besser
als kämpfen
drastischer Themenwechsel Deutschland
lag ganz weit vorne vor zehn Jahren bei
den Reaktionen auf die Katastrophe von
Fukushima das war ein Erdbeben unter dem
Pazifischen Ozean eine Flutwelle die
Japans Ostküste überrollte und die
Sicherheitssysteme des Kernkraftwerks
Fukushima lahm legte mehr als 18.000
Menschen kamen ums Leben
durch das Beben und die Flut nach allem
was man weiß verstarb ein Mensch Jahre
später an den Gesundheitsfolgen der
Strahlung wobei da Langzeitwirkungen
natürlich offen bleiben in Deutschland
beschloss damals Merkels Koalition aus
Union und FDP eine energiepolitische
Rolle rückwärts kein anderes Land hat
vergleichbar reagiert auch Japan nicht
für die einen war das überfällige
Vernunft für andere sinnlos teures
Fähnchen nach dem Wind hängen aber es
wird jetzt konsequent durchgezogen
übermorgen gehen das KKW Brokdorf und
zwei weitere vom Netz im Laufe des
nächsten Jahres folgen die letzten drei
und dann ist die Kernforderung der
Kernkraftgegner endgültig erfüllt
Hermann Bernd berichtet vom einstigen
Brennpunkt dieser Bewegung heute
schon von weitem zu sehen direkt hinter
dem Elbdeich am 31 Dezember geht die
Anlage für immer vom Netz das aus schon
ein emotionaler Moment für die rund 300
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter vor Ort
sagt Uwe Jordan der das Kernkraftwerk
seit 16 Jahren leitet die Gefühle sind
gemischt also zum einen natürlich Wehmut
das jetzt die Anlage
abgeschaltet wird der Zustand der Anlage
ist nach wie vor sehr gut der technische
Zustand auf der anderen Seite haben wir
aber als Betreiber auch akzeptiert dass
jetzt das Gesetz auch so umgesetzt
werden muss wie es festgeschrieben
worden ist
1986 wenige Monate nach Tschernobyl war
das AKW in Betrieb gegangen von Anfang
an gab es heftigen Widerstand gegen das
Projekt die größte Demo im Februar 1981
mit mehr als 100.000 Teilnehmern und
heftigen Ausschreitungen rund 500
demonstrierende und 81 Polizisten wurden
dabei verletzt
alles Geschichte sagt der 79-Jährige
Carsten Hinrichsen der in den 70er
Jahren von Hamburg nach Brokdorf Umzug
und der seitdem die Proteste
unterstützte
ich freue mich still aber stetig dass
das Ding nun abgeschaltet wird es ist
keine Euphorie
manche fragen mich ob das jetzt so ein
Sieg wäre nein ist es nicht dafür hat
das viel zu lange gedauert 45 Jahre wenn
das nach der ersten Demo abgeschaltet
oder gar nicht gebaut worden wäre das
das werden sie gewesen rund 1000
Einwohner hat Brokdorf das ausbringe
durchaus auch Nachteile sagen viele
weniger Gewerbesteuern etwa im AKW
selbst bereiten Sie sich jetzt auf den
schwierigen Rückbau vor als erstes wird
mit Januar der Reaktorkern entladen und
die 193 Brennelemente kommen ins
abklingbetten Entsorgung des nuklearen
Erbes bis 2039 sollen die Arbeiten
dauern die meisten der 300 Mitarbeiter
behalten dafür ihren Job
wir haben langfristige
Zukunftsperspektiven geschaffen für die
eigenen Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Rückbau das ist ja noch eine große
Aufgabe die vor uns liegt und die wir
jetzt 22 und 23 richtig beginnen wollen
nämlich die Anlage von innen nach außen
zurückzubauen Schritt für Schritt
Brokdorf galt übrigens immer als eines
der zuverlässigsten Atomkraftwerke
weltweit und erzeugte seit 1986
insgesamt 380 Milliarden Kilowattstunden
Strom
Robert Habeck ist als Bundesminister für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
verantwortlich als Vizekanzler ist der
mitverantwortlich für die gesamte
Regierungspolitik guten Abend guten
Abend Herr Kleber hätte es den
Atomausstieg 2011 nicht gegeben könnte
man heute bis zu 18 Kohlekraftwerke
abschalten für das Klima wäre das
bedeuten besser war der Ausstieg eine
klimasünde nein der Atomausstieg ist
richtig und wir sehen auch an den
anderen Ländern dass die Wartung der
Atomkraftwerke sehr sehr teuer ist das
gilt auch für Frankreich wir steigen
jetzt sehr schnell aus als europäisches
Land aber wir haben diesen Weg bewusst
gewählt und wir können die Klimaziele
auch mit dem Atomausstieg erreichen sie
werden die Klimaziele zunächst mal
verfehlen in diesem Jahr und im nächsten
und wer weiß was danach kommt das ist
richtig aber das liegt daran dass in den
letzten Jahren zu wenig erneuerbare
ausgebaut worden es liegt natürlich
immer an der vorigen Regierung was im
Moment schief geht in ein paar Jahren
seine Nützlichkeit aber an ihnen kann es
tatsächlich nicht liegen trotzdem die
bewertungsfrage ich verstehe die Logik
noch nicht warum ist es egal dass 18
Kohlekraftwerke weiterlaufen müssen weil
die Atomkraft wegfällt obwohl damit eine
enorme CO2 Belastung einhergeht nein das
ist natürlich nicht egal wir müssen
jetzt schnell aus der Kohle auch raus
und der Weg ist klar zu beschreiben wir
brauchen einen sehr schnellen massiven
Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien die
werden dann die große Menge an Strom und
Energie der soll dann ja umgewandelt
werden auch für den Verkehrssektor oder
für die Industrie in Wasserstoff
beispielsweise den werden wir brauchen
in Deutschland und für die Lücken die es
immer mal wieder geben wird wird
vorübergehend Gas Gaskraftwerke benötigt
und die sollen dann möglichst schnell
ebenfalls auf Wasserstoff umgestellt
werden und wenn wir das gut hinkriegen
sind wir in 15 Jahren in 13 Jahren
soweit dass wir es geschafft haben aber
wird uns schon einig wann wir bedeuten
weiter wenn man jetzt schon 18
Kohlekraftwerke abschalten könnte weil
man hätte andere Probleme dann hätte man
natürlich weniger Kohlestrom
logischerweise aber wir hätten viel
Atomstrom und die Probleme sehen wir
gerade in Frankreich beispielsweise sind
zeitgleich mit dem Abscheiden von drei
Atomkraftwerken in Deutschland vier vom
Netz gegangen in einem Volumen das
größer ist als die deutsche Abschaltung
die werden jetzt vorübergehend nur vom
Netz gehen aber sie müssen für sehr viel
Geld gewartet werden und die Schätzungen
wie viel Milliarden Euro aufgebracht
werden müssen für die französischen
Atomkraftwerke um die flott zu halten
gehen in die dreistelligen Zahlen das
heißt das wäre teure Tasse Tee geworden
also Atomkraft statt Kohle ist auch
nicht die richtige Antwort die richtige
Antwort ist Ausbau der Erneuerbaren und
dann schnell Gas zu
wasserstoffkraftwerken machen
mittelfristig macht der Atomausstieg
Deutschland auch abhängiger von Russland
als Gaslieferant zum Beispiel
über die Leitung nordstream 2 von der
sie im Sommer im Wahlkampf gesagt haben
mit uns in der Regierung wird dieses
Projekt nicht weitergehen jetzt sind sie
an der Regierung wird es weitergehen
nach dem 2 ist in der Zwischenzeit
fertiggestellt worden und sogar mit Gas
befüllt worden es steht eine Genehmigung
aus zwei ehrlicherweise eine der
Bundesnetzagentur die meiner
Fachaufsicht unterliegt und der
europäischen Institution und diese
Genehmigung wird geprüft nach Recht und
Gesetz nicht nach Politik sie haben
einen politischen Willen gehabt dieses
Projekt nicht voranzubringen sie hätten
jetzt die politische Macht es zu stoppen
ja aber wir sind ein Rechtsstaat und
Genehmigung werden nach Recht und Gesetz
erteilt die Politik muss sich auf das
politische Feld
konzentrieren und das muss man dann
außenpolitisch und geopolitisch
analysieren das heißt mit Blick auf die
Situation in der Ostukraine und den
Tuppen Aufmarsch der russischen Armee
dort wird man politisch zu entscheiden
haben welche Sanktionen
gegebenenfalls erlassen werden wenn es
dort zu einem erneuten heißen Konflikt
kommt nun hat die Ukraine kürzlich an
Afghanistan vorgeführt bekommen wie
schnell der sogenannte Westen seine
Verbündeten im Stich lässt und die
Ukraine legt großen Wert darauf dieses
Monopol auf Gasleitung fast Monopol auf
Gasleitungen aus Russland nach
Westeuropa zu haben
wir erklären Sie Ihren ukrainischen
Gesprächspartnern dass Deutschland
möglicherweise die konkurrenzlinie weil
das Recht nun mal so sei eröffnen wird
also ukrainischer Sicht und ich würde
das Teilen ist der weitere Bau der
zweiten Gaspipeline durch die Ostsee
also Nord Stream 2 eine Abkehr des
Westens Europas von der Ukraine der
Fokus schwindet ein bisschen und das ist
tatsächlich zu befürchten wenn wir ist
ein gegen Fokus aufbauen und das tun wir
wir versuchen die Ukraine als
energiepartnerland für die erneuerbaren
Energien zu unterstützen es gibt einen
grünen Fond den wir aus Deutschland
stark unterstützen wir haben gute
Möglichkeiten mit der Ukraine das den
Wasserstoff von dem ich gerade
gesprochen habe in einer Partnerschaft
zu produzieren und das ist dann der Weg
dass der Fokus Europas von der Ukraine
nicht verschwindet sollte nur aus dem
zwei genehmigt werden nun wird in der
aktuellen militärische aufgeheizten
Situation
die NATO Waffen an die Ukraine liefern
Deutschland hat das bisher blockiert
jetzt kürzlich hat Deutschland diesen
Widerstand aufgegeben im Fall von
Drohnen abwehrwaffen die nun auch mit
deutscher mindestens stummer Zustimmung
geliefert werden können was hat sich
geandert an der deutschen Haltung in der
waffenfrage
das ist ein Vorgehen das mit den
NATO-Partnern abgestimmt war und dass
man den Schutz der ukrainischen
Zivilbevölkerung und der Soldaten auf
diesem Weg sicherstellt freut mich sehr
es gab ja eine Debatte im Sommer und für
mich ist das eine gute Nachricht nun
wollen die Amerikaner und Russen und
darüber sind viele sehr erleichtert in
Genf anfangen Januar über die Lage in
Mittelosteuropa verhandeln Europäer
sitzen nicht mit am Tisch ist das in
Ordnung dass die dort stören würden
nein es gibt ja auch europäische Formate
das noch mal die Format also Deutschland
Frankreich Russland die Ukraine das
wieder belebt werden sollte es gibt die
NATO russlandrat NATO das sind die
europäischen Länder mit dabei und
natürlich sind bilaterale Gespräche auch
immer sinnvoll wenn die USA und Russland
miteinander reden kann das nur gut sein
aber Deutschland und Russland Europa und
Russland die müssen auch on speaking
terms bleiben das heißt also miteinander
in den in die Diskussion kommen am Ende
kann es ja nur immer diplomatische
Lösung von allen politischen Krisen
geben etwas anderes zu wollen etwas
anderes zu denken oder anzustreben das
wäre ja Wahnsinn nun nochmal es geht um
Mittelosteuropa und es gibt ein
verhandlungsformat über dieses Thema
direkt zwischen Washington und Moskau
und da sitzt Europa nicht mehr der am
Tisch wie kann das in Ordnung sein ja
wie schon sagte alles was zu Lösung von
Konflikten führt ist erstmal prinzipiell
in Ordnung europa sollte sich nicht
darauf ausruhen sondern seine eigenen
Formate seine eigenen Chancen nutzen was
tun Sie persönlich für die Ukraine die
ihnen offenbar am Herzen liegt dieser
vorn dieser grüne Form von dem ich
gesprochen habe wird von meinem
Ministerium verwaltet das heißt das Geld
sind ungefähr 150 Millionen Euro die der
Moment drin stehen zur Verfügung für den
Start einer grünen Energieinfrastruktur
in der Ukraine und eine
Energiepartnerschaft zwischen der
Ukraine und Europa Deutschland gar
herzustellen das wäre tatsächlich sehr
sehr geboten und sehr gut und wenn sich
die corona-lage ein bisschen entspannt
hat dann habe ich mir fest vorgenommen
zeitnah in die Ukraine zu reisen um das
vielleicht auch politisch zu
unterstützen Herr Habeck danke für das
Gespräch und einen schönen Abend ich
danke Ihnen und ich danke Ihnen für 19
Jahre scharfe Fragen ich glaube sie
haben Deutschland ein bisschen klüger
gemacht vielen Dank Herr Kleber danke
schön
das Gespräch hatten wir tatsächlich vor
einer Stunde Karl Lauterbach hat heute
angesprochen was im Grunde allen längst
klar war aber diesmal sagt es der
verantwortliche Minister in aller
Offenheit
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
geht angesichts der feiertagsbedingten
untererfassung der
corona-infektionszahlen von einer hohen
Dunkelziffer aus die sieben Tage
Inzidenz liege nach seiner Einschätzung
zwei bis dreimal höher als derzeit
ausgewiesen das Robert Koch-Institut gab
die Inzidenz heute mit
205,5 an leicht niedriger als gestern
40.00043 Neuinfektionen wurden binnen 24
Stunden registriert
5616 weniger als vor einer Woche
414 weitere Menschen starben mit oder an
dem Virus
und in Frankreich ist die Zahl der
Neuinfektionen binnen eines Tages auf
208.000 gestiegen nach dem
tageshöchstwert gestern von 180.000 vor
allem wegen der hochansteckenden
omegronvariante verzeichnen auch die USA
Großbritannien Spanien und Portugal
Rekordzahlen neuer Fälle obwohl fast 90%
der Portugiesen vollständig geimpft sind
liegt die sieben Tage Inzidenz dort bei
685 die traditionellen Straßenfeste in
Portugal zu Silvester sind verboten
internationale Kritik zieht Russland auf
sich mit einem Gesetz für medizinische
pflichtuntersuchungen für deutsche und
andere Ausländer von heute an müssen
sich Zugereiste mit Arbeitsvisum die
sich länger als 90 Tage in Russland
aufhalten zwangsweise testen lassen etwa
auf Drogenkonsum Tuberkulose
Geschlechtserkrankungen oder Aids
Wirtschafts- und Journalistenverbände
warnen vor Missbrauch der Daten und
Abwanderung aus Russland ein Gericht in
Moskau hat jetzt auch die Schließung der
menschenrechtszentren von Memorial
angeordnet nach dem Verbot seiner
Dachorganisation durch den Obersten
Gerichtshof gestern das Gericht
bestätigte heute damit den Vorwurf der
Staatsanwaltschaft der aktiven
Unterstützung von Extremisten vor dem
Gericht protestierten Anhänger memorials
die menschenrechtszentren setzten sich
für politisch Verfolgte in Russland ein
sowie für Migranten und Homosexuelle
in Hongkong müssen die Menschen einen
weiteren Schlag gegen die Pressefreiheit
hinnehmen chinesische Behörden haben
noch ein unabhängiges Medium geschlossen
das Online-Magazin stand News 7
Journalisten wurden festgenommen wegen
des Vorwurfs der Verschwörung zum
Veröffentlichen aufrührerischer Texte
mehr als 200 Polizisten durchsuchten die
Redaktion und Privatwohnungen bereits im
Juni musste die prodemokratische Zeitung
Apple daily unter dem Druck der Behörden
aufgeben
die großen expressiven Maler der
Gemeinschaft Brücke waren weltweit schon
als Helden von Ausstellungen mit
Rekordbesucherzahlen erfolgreich so wie
jetzt in Berlin in dem Museum dass ich
ganz den Malern der Brücke widmet wurde
ihr Werk aber noch nicht gesehen die
Schau fragt dem Titel Hus expression was
oder wer drückt sich da aus im
Expressionismus die Frage lohnt es
entsteht ein völlig neuer Blick auf die
Maler die ja damals gefeiert worden für
den Geist den sie malten den Aufbruch
aus der Enge der bürgerlichen enge die
Suche nach dem natürlichen sein
verstellter Blick stellt sich heraus der
sich die Leistungen ferner Kulturen
einverleibbter als wären sie herrenloses
Strandgut bereit zur Verwertung durch
die malerherren aus Europa Stefan
Merseburger über eine auch sehr
politische Kunstschau
sie wollten mit den Konventionen brechen
Avant sein gegen das bürgerliche
Aufbegehren Anregungen suchten und
fanden die Maler der Brücke in
ethnologischen Museen die damals noch
Völkerkunde Museen hießen die
Expressionisten waren fasziniert von den
enormen Sammlungen die zur Zeit des
Kolonialismus nach Deutschland
verschleppt wurden was wir natürlich aus
heutiger Sicht kritischer reflektieren
ist dass sie deren Herkunft
Kontexte die vor allem auch die
erwerbungstände wie die Objekte nach
Deutschland gekommen sind überhaupt
nicht thematisiert haben und auch nicht
reflektiert haben die berühmten Benin
brancen Raubkunst die auch einen Emil
Nolde begeisterte
Ernst Ludwig Kirchner gestaltete sein
Atelier als koloniales Gesamtkunstwerk
mit Möbeln Skulpturen und bemalten
Stoffen
die Künstler besuchten
Zirkusvorstellungen und sogenannte aus
heutiger Sicht menschenverachtende
Völkerschauen in denen Bewohner der
Kolonien in Zoos zur Schau gestellt
wurden
wie die meisten Menschen in Deutschland
haben sie es nicht kritisch hinterfragt
die meisten haben dann Europa nie
verlassen und natürlich war diese
Völkerkunde schauen ein ein gefühlt für
die Künstler einen Blick in andere
Welten
Kirchner malte Akte schwarze Menschen
ernannte sie mega Akte die meisten
blieben namenlos ob er sie auf
Völkerschauen fand ist nicht bekannt
in die Südsee in deutsche Schutzgebiete
wie man damals sagte reisten kurz vor
dem Ersten Weltkrieg zweimaler Emil
Nolde mit seiner Frau Ada und Max
Pechstein mit seiner Lotte Pechstein sah
die Ausbeutung der Bevölkerung im
Phosphatabbau und malte trotzdem
paradiesische südsee-idylen auch Nolde
blendete die koloniale Wirklichkeit
konsequent aus er feierte eine
Ursprünglichkeit der die Kolonialherren
längst ein Ende gesetzt hatten
malte auch Menschen die von den
deutschen katalogisiert und vermessen
wurden die Aquarelle zeigen seinen
anatomisches Interesse
gleichzeitig lassen sich zum Beispiel
gerade bei Nolde auch in den Briefen
durchaus Kommentare finden die von einer
Höherwertigkeit der weißen Rasse
ausgehen und wo auch deutlich wird dass
er diese rassische Unterscheidung immer
wieder betont und seine Frau Ada auch
die Künstler das macht die Ausstellung
im Berliner Brücke-Museum klar waren
Nutznießer des rassistischen
kolonialsystems in Frage gestellt haben
sie es nicht sie kultivierten den weißen
Blick
wir leben heute in einer Welt in der es
ziemlich leicht gemacht wird diese
künstlerischen Leistungen
differenzierter und kritisch zu sehen
eine kritische Sichtweise wird einem auf
silbertabletts und mühelos Angeboten ob
man deshalb mal locker von oben herab
auf die Maler Persönlichkeiten eines
anderen jahrhunderts runterschauen muss
ist wohl mehr als nur eine Diskussion
wert
ignorieren darf man es nicht mehr auch
das ist ein kultureller Fortschritt
Nachrichten aus einer Welt in der andere
Werte gezählt werden am deutschen
Aktienmarkt gehörte die Deutsche Bank zu
den verlierer-titeln Hintergrund ist
eine Geldstrafe von knapp neun Millionen
Euro erteilt von der Finanzaufsicht
Bafin wegen des Vorwurfs mangelhafter
interner Kontrollen bei der Berechnung
eines wichtigen Zinssatzes Frank
Bethmann worum geht es da ganz genau es
geht um den Euribor hört sich ein
bisschen kryptisch an zu diesen
Referenzzinssatz leihen sich Banken
Büroraum untereinander Geld ein
bedeutsamer zinssatzwahl von ihm
Geschäfte in Volumen von hunderten
Millionen Euro abhängen am Euribor
orientieren sich unter anderem Zinsen
für Kredite beispielsweise für
Baufinanzierungen vor einigen Jahren war
aufgeflogen das Mitarbeiter mehrerer
Großbanken bei der Berechnung dieser
Referenzzinssätze über jahreige trickst
hatten zum eigenen Vorteil Milliarden
Strafen wurden völlig und eine
eu-kontrollverordnung ins Leben gerufen
fortan können Banken nicht mehr einfach
so durch Nennung von Prozentsätzen einen
Durchschnittszinssatz wie den Euribor
oder Libor bestimmen nun müssen sie auch
durch interne Kontrollen sicherstellen
dass die Daten stimmig sind die Deutsche
Bank aber muss nun diese Strafe zahlen
weil sie zeitweise gegen diese
kontrollvorgaben verstoßen hat auch wenn
es damit wohl nicht zu einer weiteren
Manipulation des Euribor gekommen ist so
werfen die kontrolldefizite erneut kein
gutes Licht auf Deutschlands größte
ein Sprecher der Deutschen Bank teilt
heute mit dass man das Bußgeld
akzeptiere aber keine Hinweise darauf
sehe dass es in Folge der Mängel zu
Fehlern gekommen sei Frank beetmann
vielen Dank
zum Auftakt der Vierschanzentournee in
Oberstdorf da hat Lokalmatador Karl
Geiger den fünften Platz belegt der
Vorjahressieger vom Schattenberg zeigte
sich bei starkem Regen in guter Form und
bleibt in Schlagweite zum Tagessieger
Kobayashi der Japaner landete mit einem
Traumflug über 141 Meter im zweiten
Durchgang auf Platz 1
Markus eisenbichler liegt auf Rang 7
bitter lief es für Severin Freund er
wurde nach einem guten ersten Durchgang
wegen eines nicht-regelkonformen
anzugsdisqualifiziert
die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch
lauten ohne Gewähr 6 10 14 20 31 46
Superzahl 0 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-
die Umweltschutzorganisation WWF waren
vor dem größten Artensterben seit dem
Ende der dinosaurierzeit über 40.000
bedrohte Tier- und Pflanzenarten stehen
auf der Roten Liste mehr als je zuvor zu
den Verlierern zählten in diesem Jahr
etwa viele Wanderfischarten wie Lachse
und Huchen Lichtblicke gibt es laut WWF
dagegen dort wo Menschen intensiv am
Natur und Artenschutz arbeiten so wurde
in Deutschland etwa der höchste Bestand
an Großtrappen seit 40 Jahren gezählt
es gibt also auch erfreuliches gegen zum
Glück zum Glück gegen 23.45 meldet sich
Nazan göktem hier mit unserem heute
journal-update wir melden uns morgen
wieder bis dann
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter es ist viel zu
mild für die Jahreszeit und die Zufuhr
warmer Luftmassen ja die hält weiterhin
an und die warmen Luft kommt vom
Atlantik her dabei sind auch regenbänder
die uns im Tagesverlauf morgen
überqueren werden Sie sehen ja eins was
sich allmählich ostwärts bewegt und im
Nordosten Deutschlands da ist es ja noch
eisig kalte und so gibt es in der Nacht
wieder gefrorene Böden beziehungsweise
Regen der auf diesen eisigen Böden dann
noch gefriert ansonsten nach Süden in
viele Wolken und Regen aber dieser Regen
verabschiedet sich allmählich nach Osten
von Westen her lockert es wieder auf der
Wind kann auch kräftig sein die tiefsten
Temperaturen Richtung Nordosten bei -2
Grad und 13 Grad am Niederrhein und
morgen Tagesverlauf die der regenbänder
die allmählich ostwärts ziehen zum
Nachmittag und Abend kommt neuer Regen
von Westen her auf der Wind aus
Südwesten liegt die ich in Richtungen
kräftig an der Nordsee durchaus auch
stürmisch mit höchsten Temperaturen bis
sieben Grad Richtung Ostsee hier also
auch schon deutlich milder aber
vielmelder ist es Richtung
Rhein-Main-Gebiet mit 16 Grad ja so
ähnlich geht es in den nächsten Tagen
weiter an Silvestertag bis 16 Grad im
Norden viele Wolken und Regen dazu
stürmischer Wind aus südwestlichen
Richtungen und auch die folgenden Tage
bleiben mit Neujahr sogar mit sonnigen
Abschnitten damit ein schöner Abend